another Frankenstein movie how many of
these things are we going to get this
decade man holy [ __ ] did we just get one
last year I'm serious
Victor Frankenstein but some MacAvoy
says it in this movie seriously
Frankenstein
he was drunk though so Victor
Frankenstein is another telling of the
story of Frankenstein this one
concentrates more on Igor played by
Daniel Radcliffe Igor is in a circus no
one pays him any respect he runs across
Victor Frankenstein played by James
McAvoy and McAvoy it's like hey well you
can't work with me we can do some cool
[ __ ] so he goes and works for him and do
some cool [ __ ] everything that you know
that they're gonna do which includes
animating dead things going to be
completely honest with you guys about
this I was enjoying this movie
surprisingly so for a fair amount of it
I enjoyed the work relationship that
Igor and Frankenstein had in this movie
I like James McAvoy as Frankenstein he
was eccentric he was an [ __ ] he was
exactly what Tony Stark's kind of
accustomed us to it would have been
great to see Frankenstein in this movie
without a Tony Stark before him and now
now there's been Tony Stark it's like
every mad scientist has to be kind of a
brilliant narcissistic [ __ ] that we
all you know love but I did like his
portrayal I mean Frankenstein is a mad
scientist guys he is a mad scientist so
it was a solid interesting portrayal of
him I liked Igor also Daniel Radcliffe
did a good job there's a good
progression of his character before he's
kind of a whipped dog no one's ever
shown in many respect no love then he
starts getting confidence throughout
this movie a little quick for my taste
I mean beginning he's like no one's ever
shown me kindness this dude has known
nothing but [ __ ] he hangs out with
Frankenstein for a week and then he goes
to this ball and he was like oh Rico
suave in [ __ ] don't know if I bought
that the point is for what it was I was
enjoying it you know Frankenstein's
motivation you know he wants to animate
dead things you know he is going outside
the law to do it then the movie goes on
and then it just kind of falls apart in
the last act keep in mind this isn't as
bad but you remember in Fantastic Four
the movie wasn't good but you could
still see the moment where you're like
this is when everything fell apart in
production it's like that in this movie
everyone's villainous intent comes to
fruition and then everyone who had a
negative motivation or maybe they were
after Frankenstein in one way shape or
form they just kind of became cartoon
villains in the last act of this movie
is some video game Resident Evil stealth
mission that culminates in the
inevitable boss fight that's at the end
but it's funny because the boss fight in
this movie felt like a boss fight in one
of the Arkham games well one of the
first two Arkham games yeah there's no
tank in this movie so it can't be harcum
Knight but like in the slow river games
you have to use your surroundings to
kind of nerf the boss and then you use
another surrounding to hurt the boss and
you rinse and repeat it's kind of like
ocarina of time that's what's happening
in this movie but the thing is when a
game does that it feels more cinematic
when the movie does it feels more like a
video game one of these things is a
positive the other is a negative guys in
the end Victor Frankenstein was
surprisingly enjoyable I liked James
McAvoy as Frankenstein I liked Daniel
Radcliffe as Igor I liked the new
direction they took especially with Igor
in the last act of this movie happened
and it was just [ __ ] this movie just
went from a fresh new tank to a cliche
monster movie and you knew a monster was
going to be in this movie but it didn't
have to be a cliche ass video game
monster movie and in the end I will say
there's enjoyment to be had in the first
2/3 of this movie but I will say Victor
Frankenstein is probably a better time
if you're drunk
ya know it's a party is Frankenstein
drunk people just say it that way
bye guys so Victor Frankenstein have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's your favorite monster movie of
all time whatever you thought whatever
it is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more